ou sebha à 400 km de bagdad sur la
frontière syrienne une ville
officiellement sous contrôle de l'armée
américaine comme sont censés l'être
presque toutes les villes irak depuis
bientôt sept mois et fait demi-tour là
mais ici comme dans tout le reste du
pays les soldats américains d'abord
accueillis en libérateurs sont devenus
la cible d'attaqués qui chaque jour
alourdissent un peu plus le bilan d'une
guerre qui devait être rapide
pour ce qui est des attaques depuis
qu'on est ici ça n'arrête pas surtout
avant centre ville
faut avoir confiance quand son armée
toujours
en quelques mois pour beaucoup
d'irakiens l'armée américaine est passée
du statut d'armée de libération à celui
d'occupation
résultats où s'ébat les jays n'ont plus
aucun contact avec la population il ne
patrouillent que térez à l'intérieur de
leurs blindés et entre deux sorties
vivent barricadés derrière les murs de
leur quartier général
la police irakienne formé par les
américains pour assurer la sécurité en
ville n'a pas plus d'autorité
le capitaine kali la brahim et le
troisième responsable du commissariat en
un mois ses deux prédécesseurs ont été
assassinés
ça c'était la voiture de l'ancien chef
de la police un soir il a voulu rentrer
chez lui après son service et un groupe
d'irakiens lui a tiré dessus et
l'enlever on n'a jamais revu
la présence des américains à nos côtés
nous pose un vrai problème les gens nous
assimile à la population ne nous fait
plus confiance
on nous prend pour des collaborateurs
lentement comme pour beaucoup d'autres
villes irakiennes ou saiba s'est
transformée en piège pour les gi's
américains
alors pour tenter de reprendre la ville
en main l'état major américain a fait
appel aux parachutistes de la 82e
airborne c'est une véritable légende
dans l'armée américaine la 82e c'est le
parachutage sur sainte mère l'église en
normandie c'est le vietnam bien sûr mais
aussi l'intervention à mogadiscio en
somalie bref l'élite de l'armée
ces sommes vont avoir la difficile
mission de reprendre la ville en main
d'imposer la présence américaine en
patrouillant à pied dans les rues de
hussein et de fouiller chaque maison à
la recherche de ces terroristes comme il
les appelle qui ont déjà fait plus de
150 morts dans les rangs des gi's
je veux voir personne dehors pour le
moment
ils ont des équipes qui nous espionnent
un peu partout et je veux pas qu'on soit
repéré
en attendant il leur faut s'installer
quelque part ce sera dans cette maison
dont le propriétaire a eu la mauvaise
idée de s'absenter
le sergent-chef poster est un vétéran 14
ans de service
c'est l'un des rares à avoir une
expérience du combat
la plupart de ces hommes sortent tout
juste des rangs
après un peu plus d'un an de formation
ils ont été envoyés ici il ya deux mois
à peine pour faire leurs premières armes
ou g vous le plus bande danba tétouan
tout dire tous ses meubles dehors toi tu
me démolit smur ue et les autres faits
niant vouloir donner un coup de main
[ __ ] ça commence à bien
en un quart d'heure la maison est vide
et pour être transformé en qg
et qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est propriété
revient
les hommes de garde ont à peine le temps
de prendre position sur le toit que le
ton est donné
je crois qu'on tire sur les flics juste
en bas
à 24 ans le lieutenant brandt dirige
36000 sortons juste où les plus grandes
écoles difficiles djia est déjà en poste
haoussa et balle lui fait son premier
rapport
le problème ici c'est qu'il pose des
mines en ville le but c'est de les faire
exploser sur notre face à ce
style de nom
normalement quand on est mélangé à la
population locale on est à l'abri pour
atteindre les américains les irakiens
évite de tuer des irakiens
c'est très différent
l'autre jour il était en main des avec
un groupe d'enfants est quelqu'un leur a
jeté une grenade à fragmentation
il ya eu des morts irakiens et des
blessés américain
barbelés sacs de sable trancher dans le
jardin quand il rentre chez lui le
propriétaire découvre les américains
ben on s'installe chez toi jusqu'à ce
qu'ils aient la paix dans cette ville
mon dieu mais c'est qu'on lui tire
dessus ici
qu'est-ce que j'y peux
où est ta famille
en visite au village c'est mon frère
je suis désolé mais c'est comme ça et
mes enfants ils vont à l'école juste
derrière
je suis désolé pour toi mais on a besoin
de ta maison
comment ça a besoin je vais habiter au
moi je ne sais pas où vous voulez vous
que je trouve une maison où ça tu n'as
pas de voisins six mais c'est pas chez
moi
les affaires là le frigo il va être
abîmée vous l'ami allant vers le frigo
d'accord oui retourner le frigo moi je
peux pas m'en payer un autre je suis
pauvre
il veut encore mettre son frigo à
l'endroit il dit que sinon ça va
bousiller le condensateur ou un truc
comme ça
c'est le proprio je vais lui dire qu'ils
ont réquisitionné sa maison pour vous et
par tous regroupés dans une pièce on
pouvait pas me tacler pas si une tempête
de sable ou de la pluie pour les mettre
à l'intérieur
finalement l'interprète gênés nous
demandera d'arrêter de tourner
l'homme aura tout de même le droit
d'emporter quelques affaires
il repartira avec un chauffage d'appoint
et un magnétoscope pour son fils et une
haine contenue mais un peu plus grande
des américains
dans la cour les gi's fraîchement
débarquée sont déjà comme chez eux
nous on s'en fout qu'ils nous aiment ils
nous aiment pas on veut juste qu'ils
arrêtent de nous envoyer des terroristes
tout le monde nous détestent la libye la
syrie le liban l'iran le canada ou le
canada
ça vous fait quoi d'être en irak
moi je vais te dire comment je me sens
je me suis marié 9 août plus tard j'ai
été envoyé dans cet enfer sur plusieurs
fois mon meilleur ami s'est fait tué et
trois autres ont été blessés l'un d'eux
a perdu sa jambe
alors si tous les irakiens crève moi je
m'en fou
met en place un gouvernement et on se
casse d'ici
et si jamais ils nous refont des
problèmes on se prend pas la tête on
transforme le pays et d'un grand parking
on rase tout avec des bombardiers jouer
en groupe à
3 heures à peine après leur arrivée les
parades la 82e sont prêts pour leur
première patrouille
certains ont à peine 18 ans ils ont
besoin de se rassurer
seigneur tout-puissant oui est ce pour
protéger nous tout au long de notre
mission
il ya six équipes que votre main ou kid
pour nous permettre d'accomplir notre
devoir d'où
qu'elles nous aident à faire notre
devoir ici pis nous vous demandons de
nous accorder suffisamment de sérénité
pour rester maîtres de nous mêmes au nom
des écrits
dans les rue de bou said bâ on n'a pas
vu d'américains patrouiller à pied
depuis la chute de saddam hussein mais
les plus tendues sont les jeunes j l
pour eux le danger partout et tout le
monde est suspect
le propriétaire de cette maison est un
riche commerçant il est soupçonné de
financer la guérilla
venez
bravo je me mets un mec devant et un
autre derrière pour me couvrir
venait n'ayez pas peur
et toi le crétin tu surveilles cette
[ __ ] de porte n'est pas le mur c'est
cette maison qui nous intéresse si
quelqu'un me flinguer c'est depuis cette
[ __ ] de maison que ça parte car
[Musique]
les attentions doucement doucement et
qui dit doucement ma cheville corps est
avec vous
et toi tu recules tu me laisses faire
mon job et tu restes là bas s'il revient
derrière moi encore une fois fermes ta
gueule s'il revient derrière moi encore
une fois tu éclata cran après c'est ton
tour je veux personne dans mon dos quand
je fouille d'une maison
[Applaudissements]
je cherche des gens qui peuvent se
cacher
et si je trouve quelqu'un je m'en occupe
personnellement
rechercher des armes aussi
en fait je cherche tout ce qu'on peut
nous cacher
alors qu'est ce que vous avez trouvé
bougez vous le cul les mecs
seule arme trouvée par les américains
ce fusil à plomb
un peu plus loin la fouille continue
toujours dans le même quartier cette
fois un informateur a signalé la
présence d'une cache d'armes
allez-y numéro en malaisie
entre et chercher à les y bougez-vous
les maigres on rentrait dans cette
maison comme s'ils n'appartenaient
bordel soyez pas des timides allait
rentrer
du grès et des deux l'a vérifié moi
l'autre côté
sauvage forme soldats hélas c'est un peu
une formation continue
oui ils ont l'air un peu timide
en fait ils sont partagés entre la peur
de se faire tirer dessus et la crainte
de ne pas détruire la maison des gens
chez qui ils fouillent
mais quand on fait ces opérations il
faut y aller comme si c'est vous le
patron sinon les irakiens ne vous
respecte de repartir
le sergent-chef commence lui-même la
fouille mais s'aperçoit très vite que la
famille a été prévenu de l'arrivée des
gi's et les mecs dites moi un peu décalé
dans la pièce du fond là
toi tu es rentré
alors allez voir et dites moi ce qu'il
ya de blizzard
away chef ils ont déjà tout l'idée on
savait qu'on arrivait
tout est ouvert c'est comme si on
l'avait déjà fouillé le sergent walker à
26 ans il vient du new-jersey alors wait
is moi je les déteste pas je les
comprends parce qu'ils font ce que je
ferais si j'étais dans mon pays je sois
bien ou mal c'est un autre débat est ce
qu'ils savent ce qui est bon pour eux
peut-être pas de ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils font ce que je ferais si des
types patrouille est comme ça dans ma
vie
alors j'essaie de traiter avec respect
et dignité ne pas [ __ ] tout en l'air
quand je fouille
auj
tu n'as rien à cacher dis-nous sont les
armes
des armes sont effarés cela
j'avais des ub je ne serais pas resté en
irak que cela moi
c'est mon mari qui a les armes je ne
suis pas marié n'est pas marié
non je ne suis pas mal et pourquoi
que les enfants non c'est le fils de
massa était jamais vu une femme mourir
comme ça
tu veux je peux la frapper
la frappe tout de suite ça ne me pose
pas de problème
mais c'est qui ce monsieur
15 heures c'est l'heure de la troisième
prière de la journée la patrouille
rejoint sa base les fouilles sont
terminées pour aujourd'hui
en ville c'est le jour du marché aux
bestiaux mais le coeur n'est pas aux
affaires on ne parle que de l'arrivée
des parachutistes de la 82e
au mois d'avril sont entrés par la force
on les fera sortir par la force
nous nous battrons nous défendrons tous
notre terre tous les irakiens
depuis quand les résistances sont des
terroristes ils veulent juste défendre
notre pays c'est tout l'amérique dit
qu'elle est venue nous libérer
maintenant c'est à nous de nous libérer
de la mairie on dit les combattants
viennent de syrie non il n'ya que deux
irakiens
ce sont des irakiens qui se battent
un peu plus loin dans l'un des lycées de
la ville même ressentiment envers les
américains le directeur vient tout juste
de sortir de prison
tjs dont interrogés ils le soupçonnaient
d'avoir participé à des attentats
l'avenir est incertain pour le moment
les élèves ne savent pas ce qu'ils vont
devenir
ils peuvent sortir de l'école et se
faire arrêter il ya même tué sur le
champ
j'ai passé huit jours en prison
et on a un élève d'une autre classe qui
lui est emprisonné depuis plus d'un mois
les américains n'ont aucun respect pour
notre façon de vivre ils ne se rendent
pas compte que nous sommes un peuple qui
veut vivre libres
ils ne comprennent pas
ils ne savent que tu es arrêté
tout ce qu'ils nous font subir on ne
peut pas l'accepter
et on ne l'acceptera jamais
[Applaudissements]
chez les gi's c'est l'heure des rations
de combat et des dvd
au menu hamburger suvi des crackers
devant un classique sur la guerre du
vietnam
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi la différence entre ici et le
vietnam ça n'a rien à voir avec le
vietnam non ici t'as pas besoin d'aller
chercher la baston elle te tombe dessus
tout seul
nous on cherche pas les fusillades
mais quand ça arrive on s'amuse
non c'est pas les tirs de mortiers ou
les combattants de flipper
c'est moins dur pour moi que d'être loin
de ma famille
ne pas voir ma mère mon père et mon
frère
on leur dit rien de ce qui se passe ici
on en dit le minimum vraiment
on leur dit juste que tout va bien
au rez-de-chaussée le lieutenant bracq
prépare déjà les opérations du lendemain
avec une obsession protéger la vie de
tous ces jeunes soldats et surtout ne
pas leur faire partager ses doutes
c'est difficile on demande à des jeunes
soldats de 17 ou 18 ans de prendre en un
quart de seconde et la décision d'ouvrir
le feu
sérieux ça il faut du discernement il
faut être capable de contrôler ses
émotions faut avoir envie de continuer à
aider même si on se fait tirer dessus
ragueneau de se dire que tout le monde
n'est pas l'ennemie ici
vous avez déjà tué
si j'ai tué moi alors là je ne sais pas
au match
j'ai vidé mon chargeur j'ai vidé mon
chargeur avec d'autres
et en face je sais qu'il ya eu cinq
morts
mais je ne sais pas alors là
il faut quoi pour tenir ici il faut
avoir une foi aveugle en ce qu'on fait
et moi je me demande si ce que nous
faisons ici est vraiment juste il ya
mais je suis bien obligé d'y croire
cette nuit là depuis la terrasse de leur
qg
les américains tireront plusieurs obus
de mortier sur un terrain vague de la
ville
juste pour marquer leur présence
et pour se rassurer aussi un peu